The answer is the first choice. We'll go through the steps next.
The third choice is clearly useless, since it's still in terms of p and q,
and it's also incorrect.
The second choice would be useful if it was correct, but it's just not correct.
The hint was to try squaring p - q. We get this.
Pq here is equal to n, so we can simplify this to p^2 + q^2 - 2n.
We've still got these terms of p^2 and q^2.
If we want to get an equation all in terms of n, we need to get rid of those.
But we also know was p + q is.
Let's try squaring that.
When we square p + q, we get p^2 + 2pq + q^2,
which--substituting the n for pq--is equal to p^2 + q^2 + 2n.
This looks good. If we subtract these two, we get rid of p^2 and q^2.
Now, remember, our goal is to get an equation that doesn't involve p or q,
but we have this property from the totient that we know was p + q is in terms of just n.
We're going to substitute that in.
Then we can just take the square root,
which is how we ended up with this equation here,
which was the answer to the quiz.
Now we know the value of p + q in terms of an equation only using n.
We could have these two get the value of 2p, divide that by 2,
and get the value of p.
Once we have the value of p, we factor it is, because we can divide n by p
and easily get the value of q.
So our nice little box here turns into our proof is finished.
I should emphasize that there is no difficult computation to do here.
We're doing subtraction, squaring, and multiplication.
The square root is a discrete square root, but discrete square roots are not difficult.
We know that this result will be an integer, because the value of p must be an integer.